hey do you like doing laundry me neither
but I'll tell you what I do like that
you reviewers Awards what's that you
reviewers Awards is silly goose
I'll tell you the you reviewers awards
is like the YouTube Oscars what the heck
I'm trying to do the thing you gotta get
the sets working gosh
no as I was saying that your viewers
awards is essentially like the Oscars on
YouTube if you do a search for you
reviewers awards part 1 2 3 or 4 on
YouTube you can watch last year's show
is the movie show made for the people by
the people that's right
us normal people some of the people
involved presenting the show are of
course the schmoes know Jeremy John's
Katherine reitman and Grace Randolph if
you haven't check out the channels
please listen to the podcast I'm gonna
link below it's gonna have more info for
you on the your viewers award and stay
tuned which is going to be awesome